We are back with peacemaker, John Cena.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
All right, so, you are the number one grantor
of Make-A-Wish, 650 wishes
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
you have granted.
Thank you.
When you have that kind of openness and relationship
and sort of, open heartedness towards kids, you know,
I've read that you've said, "Maybe not.
I'm in my career, I want to be present for kids"
Now you're married, "Maybe, you know,
I'm opening up more to the idea" Where are you at now?
'Cause I think you would make like, kind of the world's
greatest father.
That's a, first of all, thank you for the comment, and,
I really enjoy my life.
I have been riding a lightning bolt for quite some time now,
and I've been given opportunities to do and see things that,
man, I didn't even dream of.
And I had some pretty lofty dreams.
It's hard work.
It's hard work to balance the time I need
to run myself correctly,
it's hard work to be the best partner and husband I can be
to my loving wife.
It's hard to keep connections with those in my life
that I love.
And it's also hard to put in an honest day's work.
Just, this is just my perspective, again,
totally not qualified,
but I think just because you might be good at something is,
for me is not a strong enough reason to do that.
You have to have passion for it.
You have to have a fuel for it.
It's like saying to somebody, "Man, you know, you're,
you're pretty good with your hands.
You'd be a great carpenter"
But if I want to be an actor, I'll be an actor.
And, and just to say to somebody,
"You have a great interaction with young people"
That's flattering.
I still am flipped, and the reason I love Make-A-Wish
so much is because those aren't like,
those are those families' wishes.
It's like, "Yo, you can do anything you want"
And Make-A-Wish's list is enormous.
They literally will do anything you want.
"I want to kick it with John Cena and go see him wrestle"
That is the coolest thing I have ever heard in my life.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
It means a lot of things.
It means one, something I'm passionate about affects people.
It means two, I can be a vehicle to,
to help make a wish come true.
And it means three, when we engage, when the wish
actually happens, it's something that someone wants,
and we're the finish line, and the joy on their face.
And these are, these are individuals who are tougher
than I could ever imagine, that are going through a set of
circumstances that I just, I can't believe.
And they get to just leave all that stuff at the door
and they get to relax and escape for a little bit
and hang out and we get to talk.
I've gotten strategy tips,
I should do secret moves.
I've been able to single people out in the crowd,
I've been able to bring people in the ring.
I've been able to encourage people to create
their own wrestling characters.
I've met Make-A-Wish families multiple times and seeing
the positive development that just our interactions had.
I've received unbelievably emotional,
emotionally moving letters from parents after some,
some very tragic circumstances happened
about what the moment meant to them
and will always mean to them.
Make-A-Wish is fantastic.
But all those things considered,
I love that, I love that joy, I love that connection.
And that, that's where I'm at right now,
and it is difficult water to tread because that,
you know, everybody's like, "Well, when?"
I just know not now, you know?
I mean, your insights into people, kids, you're so right.
Do you think you have any insight into why
you have so much self-awareness?
Well, I've been honest enough to lean into my failures.
I think a lot of times when we get knocked down,
it's real easy for us to do this.
And when you stop and you do this,
and that's the only person to blame,
through hardship, through loss, through failure,
through embarrassment.
When you're the problem, you gotta lean into it
and you gotta solve it.
And in solving some pretty,
some pretty difficult problems,
you really gotta look at yourself.
And for me, stripping it down to the core
was when I'm able to look at that guy and be like,
"I'm enough"
If we have a conversation and you walk away being like,
"I don't like him"
I still feel as if I'll project
my full and authentic self to you,
and if you don't like me, I'm sorry.
And that's the way it is.
I just applaud you for talking about the failures because
it's, I think that's very real.
And again, very important for people to hear,
it's so relatable.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
It's not all (cheers),
it's like, "Yeah, I've had failures, I've changed.
I've looked at myself, I've conquered.
I know where I'm at in life.
I want to help others.
I'm not a professional"
I like, everything about you is really remarkable.
I've always been your biggest fan,
but it is really incredible to sit down and sense
what kind of a true human being you are
with no veneer and amazing proximity.
Well, I mean...
Except for the suit.
No veneer except for this giant veneer you have on.
And likewise.
These are usually like, four minute things
where you got six questions to answer,
and it goes by format, it goes by real quick.
I don't even know what you're going to use of this
'cause you have to make your timeline on the show,
and I don't care because I'm having a great time
sitting with you, talking and connecting with somebody
I admire in front of a group of strangers
that are bold enough to be here today.
Even if there's one conversation that doesn't leave
this room because they're gonna edit all this down,
you know, maybe a mother and daughter can take away
a nugget and further their relationship,
or maybe somebody in the audience can get something,
or a camera man or somebody in the soundboard booth.
You know, maybe,
maybe we can help tip the balance a little bit.
As someone who has been cut down to four and six minutes
a lot of my life in these forums,
I'm out to break the rules.
(John chuckles)
So, I think.
I appreciate it.
(upbeat music)